from the Panama papers to the latest
paradise papers leaks tax evasion is not
only an issue outside Europe after the
Panama revelations the Parliament
decided to set up an inquiry committee
to assess how the EU and member states
have been fighting money laundering and
tax evasion some new member states are
very reluctant and very slow to to
change the laws too so we can avoid tax
evasion and money laundering and this is
a big problem for the EU it's a big
problem for the majority of countries
that want to have another dinner
the crucial is a good will of the member
states and I think if there are no no
leaders in some countries which would by
the bullet I think it requires the
pressure coming from the public opinion
on members of parliament are calling for
better monitoring and effective
implementation of existing rules in the
fight against tax avoidance when we have
a look at all the leaks if any new leaks
come they provide new names of companies
or individuals but the technique is more
or less the same
among the recommendations more
traceability and an increased exchange
of information on tax payers and owners
MEP s also want proportionate sanctions
in case of any breach of law what we do
now is to ask the leadership of the
Parliament for a special committee to
shed light on on paradise papers call
witnesses call people who are mentioned
in the paralyzed papers to testify
before the European Parliament look at
these structures see how we can prevent
these structures to to be established in
the future